how are you Gabe I'm doing great sorry
I'm great how do what do you make of
this report today Gabe well this was in
Somis a long time coming I think a lot
of the allegations in this report a lot
of the allegations in the criminal
investigation are not a big surprise to
people who know anything about college
athletics particularly college
basketball I think the fact that there
are some high profile schools maybe took
some people by surprise but if you were
told that agents and financial advisers
were funneling money to college athletes
under the table is anyone really
surprised by that I think the big
surprise is that this was turned into a
criminal investigation and that people
might actually be facing prison time
jail time for this again I don't think
the the underlying violations are really
the big surprise maybe the scope of this
is and maybe the timing of this is and
then it's gonna be interesting to see
what these schools and what the
n-c-double-a does now with that
information particularly as the
basketball tournament is obviously right
around the corner okay a couple
questions for you in terms of right
around the corner
you know the NCAA President Mark Emmert
statement today it was essentially like
we are upset and we are going to sit
down and talk about it and figure this
thing out okay that essentially was his
statement so is it possible that schools
seeing that what was reported today are
talking right now
to coaches and compliance officers and
saying we've got to sit kids down just
in case to avoid any issues of vacated
wins going into a tournament is it
possible we're gonna see that over the
next several weeks Gabe I think we've
already where it's already happened I
think this stuff started to leak out
anyone who had any connection to any of
these agents or any of the executives at
adidas we're taking a long hard look at
what had gone on in their institution
and whether they knew about it at the
time or not virtually every compliance
office in this country I have to imagine
was doing these types of investigations
now they're certainly brighter red flags
that particular schools have been named
but yes certainly the big issue is if
your player is ineligible if you have a
current player
is ineligible because they received an
improper benefit and they play during
the tournament that that any potential
winds could be vacated yeah I mean there
are all these compliance officers
certainly taking a very long hard look
talking to their coaches figure out what
do we need to do how quickly do we need
to do it and what evidence can we get
and it's really hard when you have
schools all across the country and we
look at it and say well I don't want to
be first or the first one to declare my
player at eligible and so it's dangerous
to have a coordinated effort but but I
think there has to be some discussion
whether it's at the conference level or
at some other level to see what are the
expectation on the schools now I'm given
that a tournament is right around the
corner and it is the expectation that
these players but at these schools as
they're otherwise normally required to
do will self-report and we'll sit down
players if they believe there's evidence
that they received improper Bell well I
mean because there are some current
players that are being named in this
thing right now
current players current programs that
we're expecting to see in sweet 16s game
I mean there's oh yeah beloved Michigan
is not there but Michigan State is on
the list Kentucky's done all this Duke
is on the list well certainly I mean but
that's from some of them are from past
players but I mean when when miles
bridges again of Michigan State is his
mom according to expense reports
received hundreds of dollars in advances
right now is it entirely possible that
Michigan State sits there and goes
bridges you've got to sit right now like
right now starting immediately in theory
what should happen is the school would
do an investigation now that they have
this information if they get enough
evidence that he did in fact get that
money then yes I mean they're there what
they would do they would talk to the
young to the belay and say what should
we do in this situation with this
information and again I given that this
is multiple schools with players current
players and as you said these are their
high profile schools with some
expectations they'll advance far in the
tournament I don't know that this is a
situation where they want the schools to
have to make these decisions on their
own that they're going to have to
receive guidance from the n-c-double-a
and as you mentioned Mark Emmert saying
what
this is horrible let's sit down and look
at it and talk about it and then maybe
act in a few years
that doesn't help now these schools need
to know what they are supposed to be
doing right now what should these
compliance officers be doing right now
so that they don't unfairly put at risk
the rest of the team the players who did
nothing wrong but also you have to be
fair to the school ones for these
players to say look just because we have
some ledger from one agent doesn't mean
that they are necessarily responsible
for that this time it doesn't mean that
it's necessarily venting ability to
delay violation so again I think they
want to take their time make sure they
get it right sure but also don't put
their school director Tulane sports laws
gave Feldman here on the Rich Eisen show
last one for you Gabe being a veteran of
these things as you are what do you make
of the fact that these documents were
made available to two reporters of Yahoo
right in the middle of this whole thing
three weeks before the tournament
why and that not just how I mean just
why why do you think something like that
happen why is it a great question and
let me just back up ask the bigger why I
have to ask why is the government even
doing this investigation why do they
believe this rises to the level of a
criminal sense why is this something
we're spending taxpayer dollars on and
focusing on yes it may be unstable I
eventually violations at the end of the
day but the why is it something that
people may go to jail for and then on
top of that why is it information being
leaked at this time I think there a lot
of strange things going on here I don't
think there are answers to it yet well
what's your best guess what would be
your best guess on that on the broader
question I mean there's a lot of
potential explanations it could be that
they just want to make a splash okay and
then the fact that this was leaked now
does it mean that their case might not
be strong enough or or they just wanted
to somebody wanted to shake things up I
mean what would be your best guess on
that game this could be rattling the
trio's could be shaking a tree see what
else is going to fall out to start to
put pressure on the people who are named
here as you know a lot of these cases
the people who are named are not
necessarily the targets they are used as
a means to get to the bigger fish and to
try to get them to turn and say look
we've got you here if you don't
cooperate we're going
down hard on you I'm so rather than have
that happened give us more information
and it could be just a public plea to
try to get some leverage in the
investigation and maybe the
investigation hasn't turned up as much
as they had wanted to maybe it stalled a
little bit it's unclear there are lots
of different explanations it would just
be a wild guess as to why this leaked
sure now and and the information in
particular that leaked no Gabe always
appreciate the time thanks for hopping
on the phone you got it that's Gabe
Feldman director of Tulane sports law
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience